hallo Thomas ich habe eine Frage zu dem
Lied Schnee von gestern du singst in
diesem Lied von leidvollen Erfahrungen
aber auch von Glücksmomenten und für
mich geht's in diesem Lied um
Vergangenheitsbewältigung nicht von
gestern was mich interessiert
ist hat das Lied irgendeine eine
Empfehlung wie man mit Vergangenheit
umgehen soll oder ist ein bestimmtes
Gefühl damit verbunden was dieses Lied
ausdrücken soll oder
[Musik]
ja eine Haltung die zur Vergangenheit
man eint kannst du da was zu sagen was
du mit diesem Lied verbindest also ich
habe ja diesen Song halt mit Christian
bes zusammen geschrieben mit meinem
langjährigen Kumpel mit dem ich Hal
schon Musik mache und wir sind natürlich
durch Höhen und Tiefen diesem Business
gegangen
und auch wenn wenn man negative
Erfahrung macht trotzdem ist es eine
Erfahrung aus der man lernt und letzten
Endes weißt du wennn man irgendwas
negatives kann man das sowieso nicht
zurück zurückdhen wenn irgendwas
negatives passiert und deshalb sollte
man sich einfach sollte man diese diese
Erfahrung einfach mal über Bord
schmeißen ja und sagen das ist eh Schnee
von gestern unddrehen kannst es eh nicht
die Zeit also zurückdrehen und
man muss einfach mal nach vorne gucken
und genau dieses Gefühl ähm ähm wollen
wir ja vermitteln mit diesem Song